an energy Department official caught on
camera allegedly stealing luggage
according to a warrant first obtained by
eight news now good afternoon thank you
for joining us here at four I'm Kirsten
Joyce and I'm Christian Casitas it's the
story of the eight news now
investigators first broke Vanessa Murphy
joining us live in studio with the
latest Vanessa energy Department Deputy
assistant secretary Sam Britton made
headlines after being charged with
stealing Luggage in Minneapolis Metro
Police saw those news stories and said
hey that's the person stealing luggage
over this summer here in Las Vegas for a
previously unsolved case now as we first
reported yesterday a warrant is issued
for Britain for a felony charge police
say Britain posted a selfie at the
airport wearing the same t-shirt that's
seen in the video Britain takes the
victim's luggage from the carousel looks
at the tag puts it back on the carousel
looks around to see if anyone's watching
and then takes the luggage now the owner
of that luggage filing a police report
and estimating the value of her luggage
and her belongings in it at nearly
thirty seven hundred dollars the theft
is alleged to have happened in July but
police say they identified Britain as
the suspect in November again after
seeing Britain already making headlines
for a similar crime Britain is 35 years
old a deputy's assistant secretary at
the office of nuclear energy but on
leave after facing charges in
Minneapolis that case is ongoing we
tried reaching Britain's attorney we
were either disconnected or he hung up
on me back to you Christian